Sentence.
So if he doesn't get elected,
do you think he goes and starts a podcast TV network he took?
Totally could.
Yeah.
He totally could probably be better for him,
honestly.
That's what he thought he was going to do.
I think before he got elected,
I think he was having high level meetings with people in the media space to
start something like that.
Well,
once NBC fired them,
NBC fired and while he was running because of stuff that he said about Mexico
and the throw rapist,
like someone's doing the raping,
right?
Too late talk.
This is so fucking crazy out of control for a person running for president and
NBC is like,
that's it.
We're getting rid of you.
And then they put Arnold in his place and that was a disaster.
Do you remember that people forgot Arnold hosted the apprentice.
You're fired.
Yeah.
That was,
oh,
that was horrible.
It was terrible.
Yeah.
Trump was shitting on them.
They did.
They just scrapped the show after that.
Yeah,
of course.
Here's a question.
Does he go back to the apprentice after?
Well,
if NBC presidency,
I think he's too toxic now.
I think some way to toxin toxic.
Maybe you could come up with something like that for Fox.
Oh Fox is in this scoop him up.
That's what's great about Fox.
They'll play ball.
I'll play ball.
They're not going to leave money on the table.
You know what though?
They did want Megan Kelly back to like,
well she did a thing.
I'd used to do the show red eye on Fox News,
which was comics would just try to be funny.
They aired it at like 3:00 AM east coast time and I saw her the week she was
doing that and she was in like the dressing room and she knew she shouldn't have
left.
She can feel it.
She had already made the decision but you could kind of see it in her face that
I think she knew that she was going to try to be this daytime TV queen and like
let's bake cupcakes.
You know,
I just spent four years on Fox News talking about sanity and white,
but now let's bake cupcakes cause I'm,
I'm America's sweetheart.
That's never going to work.
Well,
it's weird when you publicly change your image,
it's insane.
Publicly changing your image.
Shoot her shirts or skirts got longer.
Oh yeah,
she covered her neck or yeah.
You know,
there's no more cleavage.
Every show was about sexual assault.
She was telling me every single show is about sexual assault.
I think she was trying to ingratiate herself in with the people that hated her,
which was like the New York media types,
the people that did not like her.
And then she was like [inaudible] even just about sexual assault.
Like one of them was a lady who fuck Matt Lauer and she knew she was fucking him
and she was talking about a lot of Shit fucked him.
Well I didn't know any better.
I was 25
25 if fuck the guy,
you fuck what happened?
It's bad here.
Right?
Well he shouldn't have fucked it cause he was married.
Okay.
After that,
what happened?
What's going on?
Nothing.
You just fucked him.
Who he was.
What?
Why is this a segment of a show?
Is it because it's scandalous?
Did an interview with her.
Yeah.
Great.
Yeah,
it was,
you know,
and she was saying,
I was young and I was impressionable,
which sure,
of course you're funny to see them all put nails in each other's coffins.
Isn't that great?
Media is like this blood feud.
There's only a few families that control all of this information.
They all hate each other.
That's why succession is such a great show.
Well,
I think with Megan it was like that.
She had been sexually harassed while she was at Fox News.
Oh,
he's going after I was at your house.
Yeah.
So she was going after,
and I think bill O'Reilly too.
I think there was some,
some insinuation 38 million.
So it's like,
what did he do?
I think it was 32 32 or 38
and my grants,
my grandfather still has a bill O'Reilly patriots welcome doormat.
Wow.
You know,
it's a good Matt.
I mean,
imagine that's a giant amount of money.
It's the amount of money where what he did should be.
I mean,
it seems like it's an,
it could be a Netflix documentary.
Let's got to be,
it's like horrific.
Like he offered her 37 million.
She's like,
no,
keep going.
Yeah.
Right,
right.
I'm going to need more after what you did to me is a $32 million offense.
We'll do,
what's that one recording the left on some assistance.
Pantry in that chorus.
That woman?
Yeah.
Loofa sponge or something.
I mean that's his,
that's what he was trying to do.
That's how creepy old guy move.
Yeah.
Gotcha.
With a sponge.
10 interesting.
He tried to have his ex wife.
He tried to have his ex wife excommunicated from the church.
What grade did he,
oh,
he tried.
I mean know that why?
Well,
cause he wanted her to go to hell.
A church.
Catholic church.
What kind of donation you have to make to get your ex wife sent to hell?
Probably 32 million.
He's got it.
But he wanted her ex communicated.
That's type of guy.
He is.
But the crazy thing is,
even after all this,
the guys still had a number one book in The New York Times bestseller seller.
People dig in.
They still,
those old fuckers,
they just give in.
They dig in,
they don't care.
They like them.
They might know who he is.
Folksy.
He's liked by your uncle.
He's a good man.
He's spent spend $40 million for some woman.
He tortured.
The tide goes in,
the tide goes out.
I'm with God.
That what he was doing that that fucking Todd goes in,
the tide goes out.
You can't explain it.
When I was like,
wow,
you went to Harvard,
you fucking piece of shit.
Yeah.
Well you could explain that those guys are,
they were religion like a fuck.
It's fashionable to wear it.
They wear it.
They know.
Sure Trump doesn't.
He gets out and he goes,
I'm a Christian.
I may not be the best Christian,
but I'm a Christian.
Leadership caught enough.
It's good enough.
You know and you're like not the best Christian.
You're a thrice married guy who owns gambling and a Miss Universe pageant.
You're a biblical fit.
That's like a biblical figure that would be like a Roman king that everybody was
warned about.
Like in terms of like,
I mean,
I want him to shave his head.
What do you think that will do?
I just freedom.
I think it'd be funny if you shaved it like somebody had a cancer issue when he
just shaved it with them to be a good guy.
Well,
it doesn't look good.
That's what's confusing to me.
Like when I realized that as a style,
when my hair wasn't looking good,
[inaudible] rid of it was impossible to look good.
It was falling out to the point where like,
this is a mess.
Then I went and buzzed it.
But he,
uh,
I just remember you like this to my generation.
Always remembers.
You liked the gist of Harold [inaudible].
Yeah.
It's nice.
I've been,
I've been like this for a long time.
Yeah.
I'm solid.
Eight plus years bald.
How do you want Trump to just go?
Hmm.
I think you'd be better off.
It'd be easier.
Like he's not good looking.
Like he know that he would,
that would complete his transformation into a super villain,
I guess.
Like a Lex Luthor type go.
Yeah.
But just like,
I just,
it's gotta be so much work to put that hair together.
I think someone does it from,
but even then,
you've got to talk to them whether putting it together.
I bet you he doesn't talk to them.
Everything he does just tweets angry.
I bet you he's not concerned with the human relations with his staff.
No.
Let's just get that vibe and get that vibe.
I get that.
Five,
the person who's in charge of the hair just does the hair.
I hope he retired when he retires or when he's done.
I hope he goes right into podcasting.
Would you have them on right now?
Yes.
Yeah,
of course.
You have to.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
For sure.
Yeah.
Why not?
Why wouldn't he come on?
Uh,
[inaudible] he's busy and I had some jokes about him.
He's petty.
He hates comedy.
He does not like to be made fun of.
He doesn't like to be made fun of.
Yeah.